bonjour à tous et bon jour à tout
je suis ravi d'être parmi vous alors
aujourd'hui donc je vais enchaîner un
peu avec ce les craintes exprimées par
lies karak et également ce que veut ce
que vient de dire ma collègue s'est bien
chargé
aujourd'hui donc je vais vous parler de
l'environnement pas dans le sens le
large mais je vais m'intéresser au gaz à
effet de serre et leur impact sur
l'environnement donc le réchauffement
climatique alors la première chose par
lequel on va commencer
c'est ce que les craintes partagées
alors d'où viennent ces craintes
il ya des certitudes les certitudes ils
viennent du fait que puis il y a des gaz
à effet de serre plus il fait chaud à
c'est tout le monde est partagé
ça a été repris dans les médias elle a
été repris dans les télévisions
donc le émissions de co2 dans
l'atmosphère a doublé a plutôt augmenté
dans l'ordre de 30% et c'est énorme
donc les recherches sur les origines
c'est les combustibles fossiles impliqué
dans pas mal de domaines dont on vient
de parler tout à l'heure
ma collègue donc le problème qui se pose
maintenant c'est une question alors
moyens non ses certitudes là donc on ya
des inquiétudes
est-ce qu'on va source nous serons
soumis à un réchauffement qui va
produire une sécheresse donc une
température qui va
grand baie la fonte de glace les
tournantes
donc la question tout bête banal anodine
c'est quelques éléments pour demain
alors quel climat bon bien sûr c'est que
vous intéresse il au quotidien
donc le climat pour demain c'est on ne
s'intéresse est-ce qu'on va est-ce qu'on
va avoir
demain tout ce qu'on a aujourd'hui geder
je vais partir de quelque chose ce qui
est simple ce qu'on va manger des
oranges d'ici 2030 2050
donc est ce qu'on peut se promener faire
des balades faire des randonnées
est-ce que c'est verdure synergies
existent les palmeri les oasis les
permis et enfin et aura-t-elle de
pastèques
j'ai choisi cette formule 1 parce que
d'ici 2030 2050 on va minimiser le
volume pour remplir le plus est par la
suite réduire le coût de transport
bon alors le problème ici c'est que il
faut agir le agir d'accord mais agir
comment agir sur quoi la crainte
simplement quand on ne sait pas on
risque de passer du bon côté au mauvais
côté donc la meilleure chose la
meilleure méthodologie c'est de
comprendre comprendre sur quoi agir
comprendre comment agir alors la
première chose que je vais essayer avec
vous d'exposer c'est l'effet de serre ce
phénomène physique comment on va
l'expliquer commencé s'explique quelque
sorte
alors nous avons tous pas donc le soleil
émet un rayonnement
solaire dont le pic se situe dans la
région savez très bien que quand on
dessine le soleil on la coloration c'est
toujours jaune tout simplement parce que
la longueur d'onde maximal de l'émission
de soleil c'est du jaune
alors une fois ça tombe sur le sol le
rayonnement solaire
alors j'ai représenté rouge ça veut pas
dire que ces rayonnements rouge c'est un
à rayonnement infrarouge on ne le voit
pas donc ils se situent dans les
longueurs d'onde tout à l'heure ma
collection et à vous a montré le spectre
s'est intéressé aux radars et tout ça
mais c'est juste avant le prochain dans
le proche infrarouge et l'infrarouge
lointain donc le la terre va émettre
suivant des longueurs d'onde de l'ongle
lent alors je mets l'atmosphère qu'est
ce qui se passe voilà donc l'atmosphère
va réfléchir tout ce qu'on va y mettre
la terre ça chauffe ça va continuer à
chauffer donc ça chauffe encore alors la
question maintenant comment faire il
faut comprendre que tout se passe au
niveau de la couche de l'atmosphère donc
dans à peu près dans les 50 km ont ça
peut aller jusqu'à 100 mais on va on va
on va s'intéresser aux 50 kg mais alors
juste un exemple simple pour fixer les
idées sans atmosphère si j'enlève
l'atmosphère un calcul simple
la température moyenne à la surface de
la terre c'est moins 18 degrés quand on
met l'atmosphère refait le calcul
la température moyenne est de 15 degrés
celsius donc l'atmosphère est
responsable à peu près de 33 degrés donc
chose est simple conclusion simple qu'on
peut tirer donc la première conclusion
qu'on peut tirer
finalement les faîtières c'est un
phénomène naturel qui est totalement
indispensable à la vie sur terre
donc on dit en le présentant en tant
qu'ennemi alors que c'est pratiquement
notre ami les faîtières les gaz à effet
de serre le problème c'est quoi
finalement ce n'est pas les gaz c'est
pas leur présence le pré
est indispensable à la vie sur terre le
problème c'est qu'en tant mobily les
proportions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est là que les catastrophes commence
bon je dirais pas catastrophe les
inquiétudes
je ne veux pas vous en foulée il faut
rester optimiste
alors là c'est une autre schématisation
du rayonnement solaire
alors pourquoi j'ai fait cette sauce
light c'est tout simplement pour dire
que les gaz à effet de serre se situe
dans une couche très minces
cette couche mince qui contient elle
contient un peuple et elle contient donc
les gaz les l'ensemble des gaz qu'est ce
qui est à combien alors regardez ces six
et je fais le la des comptes la
comptabilité les gaz à effet de serre
les gaz à effet de serre sont le reste
de n2 et de l'est le reste de l'oxygène
donc les moyens reste pas grand chose
vous avez 70 % le n 2 et renforçons
d'oxygène donc finalement il ne reste
pas grand chose alors les gaz à effet de
serre c'est quelle proportion
la proportion des gaz à effet de serre
donc c'est ça ne dépasse pas les 1 %
donc finalement comme on dit et en eau
chaude albert tram foutent rien que
c'est c'est le 1 % ces mêmes ou dessous
de 1% alors les la caisse qui a le plus
important et gaz à effet de serre
lesquels je vais pas l'origine d'où ils
viennent déjà l'origine des gaz à effet
de serre c'est un peu toutes les
activités humaines tant que j'ai mis
vous savoir de l'allumage du feu
forestier jusqu'à pratiquement
l'utilisation des dans la technologie
des réfrigérateurs
donc vous avez le méthane les dérivés du
carbone le protoxyde d'azoté et le co2
tout ça toute cette proportion qui
existe dans l'atmosphère ne représente
pas le 1 % de la composition de
l'atmosphère
alors le
le le disant la chose qui caractérise
qui est importante qui caractérise ces
gaz là c'est ce que j'appelle le pouvoir
radiatif alors le pouvoir radiatif par
exemple c'est en proportion relatif au
co2 donc par rapport si je prends pour
ces deux unités
le méthane c'est en trente deux fois le
pouvoir radiatif de co2 le protoxyde
d'azoté 60 fois alors les crj cds
dérivés de carbone qu'on utilise
généralement dont les gaz dans les
réfrigérateurs
il le présente à peu près 16 mille fois
pouvoir radiatif plus que le co2 bon ça
heureusement on a comme on a interdit
l'utilisation de ce type 2
de produits depuis vers la fin des
années 90 je vais je vais ensuite parlé
un peu les activités humaines donc tout
est lié
pratiquement l'activité anthropique donc
l'activité humaine lassé et vous pouvez
voir c'est un peu suivant chaque domaine
ça c'est l'exemple de la france c'est ce
que deux mois et fsu rieuse mans donc
alors on peut trouver que 65 74 % 10 %
les 74% donc co2 c'est la raison pour
laquelle on va il faut se concentrer sur
la réduction des émissions de gaz
carbonique
la proportion est énorme vu l'activité
humaine voilà alors ça c'est
pratiquement les principaux gaz à effet
de serre et on a d'autres mais des
proportions très très réduite
la vapeur d'eau la vapeur d'eau c'est un
gaz à effet de serre c'est le gaz le
plus actif dans l'infrarouge
seulement c'est un ami tout simplement
il séjourné quelques semaines quelques
jours dans l'atmosphère et ensuite télé
transformé sous forme de pluie le
deuxième co2 co2 deux possibilités il ne
se transmet une heure ils ne
disparaissent pas facilement il séjourne
il séjourna à peu près entre 50 et 200
ans
oui bon je passe donc le co2 on va se
concentrer sur ses deux pourvu le
pouvoir radiatif et vu la durée de
séjour dans l'atmosphère alors juste
pour vous donner une idée sur eux
au 1850 les proportions de co2 et de
méthane le protoxyde d'azoté
donc vous voyez très bien que des
concentrations d'ici 2030
ces concentrations ray deviennent
inquiétantes donc l'effet de serre va
s'intensifier
quel est l'impact quel est l'impact donc
pour voir l'impact de co2 on essaie de
voir comment évolue la concentration
alors vous voyez très bien là une
représentation qui va 2750 jusqu'à 2100
alors on prend les les valeurs on
extrapole et ça c'est un travail qui a
été fait par des centres de recherche
dans la crédibilité est indéniable donc
c'est des études sérieuses qu'est ce
qu'on voit à partir de 2002 l'an 2000
jusqu'à 2100 la simulation qu'est ce
qu'elle donne donc elle donne
pratiquement une concentration de co2
qui est inquiétant qu
donc l'obligation d'agir et et je dirais
imminente
quel est l'impact sur la température la
c la température bon dans chaque plan
c'est ça dépend de la latitude donc ce
soit vous vous êtes sur l'équateur où
vous allez vers le pôle nord
donc ça ça vous donne une idée sur
l'ordre de grandeur de la température
comment elle est plutôt de co2 et de la
température
2e
le second slight là c'est qu'elles sont
sur deux qui part dans la nature
y at il un moyen sur terre qui en train
de les séquestrer oui il ya une partie
de co2 la nature fait de sorte que ça se
produit il ya les arbres donc qu'ils
consomment pour produire de l'oxygène il
ya aussi le les océans qui séquestre qui
stocke sur deux mais c'est insuffisant
donc n'ayez pas peur il ya ceux des
jokers qui la nature a fait qu'il y ait
un mécanisme qui réduisent 7,7 ces
concentrations
je vais regarder maintenant la
température le réchauffement
l'objet de cette intervention alors la
température
donc je c'est une simulation qui va
jusqu'à 2100 et on voit très bien qu'à
partir de 2000 à partir de 2000 il ya
quand même un accroissement inquiétant
de la température c'est aussi des
simulations
cette simulation de centre sérieux je me
passerais aussi à un autre juste pour
vous montrer que les certitudes et
partager ça aussi le 0 c par rapport
donc c'est par rapport à des références
de 61,90 donc c'est le nasa la noire
c'est des études qui ont montré
vous voyez très bien qu'avant vous avant
1962 on y voit un peu au dessous de la
moyenne
et ensuite ça grimpe et les nôtres notre
courbe sur l'évolution de la température
mais par rapport à d'autres
référence par rapport à une autre
comparaison c'est ça ça représente ça
c'est également à l'or ces mesures sont
dans la majorité c'est des mesures
satellitaires
donc c'est des mesures précises alors
tout ça pour dire c'est que c'est pas
pour alarmer c'est pas pour être
pessimiste mais tout simplement pour
booster les volontés à chercher des
alternatives
là aussi c'est là c'est les conséquences
sur le niveau de la mer
donc oui alors bon on parle parfois de
deux mètres te mettre de toute façon les
prévisions scientifiques ne vont pas au
delà de 60 cm mais seulement le problème
c'est que les 60 centimètres sont aussi
responsables ils peuvent être
responsable de la transformation totale
de la carte géographique
je passe ensuite le niveau moyen des
mers de 1993 a ses raisons aussi ça
c'est des mesures satellitaires
juste pour vous donner une idée sur lies
certitude d'où ils viennent ces
certitudes là c'est des certitudes
scientifiques établis par un ensemble
avec des comparaisons je vais passer
rapidement dans que ça c'est le résumé
des différentes estimations
donc on peut retenir et donc une hausse
de température une élévation du niveau
de la main une concentration de co2 qui
augmente alors maintenant comment agir
alors pour agir bon les retombées ma
tous compris quelles sont les retombées
sur les
les l'environnement alors l'action
maintenant l'action qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire
ne rien faire quand le résultat est
connu donc maîtriser réduire l'émission
de gaz à effet de serre première chose à
faire développer l'efficacité
énergétique m en taxes a déjà installé
tacler coatex une taxation sur la
pollution et sur l'émission de carbone
donc si vous vous êtes près du lycée ne
laissez pas vos parents conduire ou
aller à pied vous y comme vous
économisez de l'énergie mais également
des gaz les vous réduisez l'émission de
co2 alors mais vous voyez très bien que
ce n'est pas seulement à l'échelle de
l'individu
ça doit être aussi une action
intergouvernementale qui dépasse
l'individu qui dépasse l'état mais c'est
une action internationale
donc là c'est on va voir on voit les
avancées des l'organisation nationale
des nations unies donc dès qu'on a
commencé dès qu'on a commencé à
comprendre et à concevoir un
environnement propice durable
les conférences ont commencé donc il va
y avoir à sa démarré depuis 4 ans et
plus sur ces 86 vous souhaitez haïti
auto johannesburg rio concon les accords
de durban en afrique du sud de la
conférence de varsovie les mains au
perron est là en 2015
c'était une conférence c'est la 20ème
conférence 21e conférence sur le climat
en france 1
j'ai repris un peu les clauses dont
par exemple le protocole de kyoto alors
tout simplement cessé d engagement qui
ne sont pas contraignants pour les états
et maintenant on va vers des
contraignants aux états alors je passe a
ensuite où la lutte donc une question
que je pose relatifs à ce que je viens
de dire quelle est l'énergie la moins
émettrice de gaz à effet de serre et
quelle est la moins polluante
tout simplement c'est l'énergie qu'on ne
consomme pas donc celle qu'on ne
consomme pas c'est celle qui n'est pas
donc je le premier message que je lance
c'est qu'effectivement essayer de ne pas
consommer d'énergie on vous sortez de
votre chambre s'assurer que vous avez
éteint la lumière ne jetez pas l'écueil
en fin d'année vous déchirer les cahiers
voulait jeter devant les lycées éviter
ça c'est pour le recycler leur cycle et
il faut se consomme de l'énergie alors
enfin donc je vous remercie
j'espère que le message est passé ça
doit démarrer de l'individu et c'est
comme les fleuves ça commence par une
goutte et merci de votre attention